it's show time we're gettin close  there's nothing like going to the  theater for me and watching those lights  go down you don't need to promote IMAX  there's something about a fully  immersive experience with sound and  visuals like it enhances everything  facial features a bigger and bigger  anomalies how ugly he is on screen so  dark you know the DC Universe while  watching Deadpool to Peter's mustache is  bigger and better and I'm any powered  want to tell us about I don't have one  um I just saw the ad you're in while  watching Deadpool - Ryan Reynolds little  shrinky dink  is bigger and better in IMAX  bring it on what I really  whoo yeah your bullets they're really  fast  [Music]